perdón reconciliación mediación
justicia palabras que hacen eco en este
teatro esta tarde todos hemos escuchado
a nuestros compañeros hablar de estos
temas
temas y condiciones o derechos que damos
por sentados porque gozamos de ellos y
muchas veces no los valoramos
yo quisiera preguntarles a todos ustedes
de los que estamos aquí presentes quien
se ha enfermado alguna vez por favor
levante la mano 15 enfermas alguna vez
todos los órganos hay arriba también
quien ha podido accesar un médico para
atenderse por la enfermedad levanten la
mano por favor
todos también
quién de los que está aquí presentes
tiene sus estudios de preparatoria
correspondiente a su edad
preparatorio más levanten la mano por
favor
muy bien quién de los que quien es de
los que están aquí han votado en esta
ocasión vas a votar por primera vez
así todos también verdad mayores de edad
y quien es de los que están aquí tienen
un trabajo formal
bueno
déjenme felicitarlos ustedes son parte
del 9% de la población mundial que tiene
acceso a esas condiciones
solamente el 9%
qué pasa con la demás gente
qué pasa con los demás ciudadanos y
alrededor de nuestras calles cercanas a
nosotros muchas veces no tienen
oportunidades y esas oportunidades o esa
falta de oportunidades nos lleva en
muchas ocasiones a dell inc ya no
justificamos la delincuencia y por
supuesto que no pero son personas
ciudadanos como ustedes como yo que se
equivocaron
que forman la cárcel
pagaron
la deuda con la sociedad de acuerdo a lo
que el juez le dictó
y salen a la calle
y salen a la calle a un mundo igual
y el que les causó el origen del
problema
a una sociedad que pocas veces somos
incluyentes como dijimos al principio
que perdonamos que vemos al prójimo como
igual a nosotros
que percibimos en los demás no una
figura física sino una persona atrás de
ellos
a nivel internacional a nivel nacional
los datos de acuerdo a la onu es que el
70% de las personas que han sido
internadas con un delito vuelven a
cometerlo al salir
70 de cada 100 o 7 de cada 10 es un dato
altísimo
pero les tengo una buena noticia
aquí en chihuahua y el día de hoy soy
portavoz de ello
y me enorgullezco de ello
se ha empezado a trabajar con el tema de
la reintegración social se empezaba a
trabajar a través de una organización de
la sociedad civil que es el concierto
ciudadano de seguridad de justicia de la
ciudad de chihuahua se ha empezado a
trabajar un problema un programa que al
día de hoy está siendo auspiciado tanto
por el pueblo de los eeuu como por el
empresariado chihuahuense a través del
fisco sé que un programa ya la fecha
después de tres años ha atendido
alrededor de 508 jóvenes
508 jóvenes que se han atendido de
manera individual
que se han analizado sus problemáticas y
se ha generado un programa integral de
atención donde se incluye una evaluación
psicológica una evaluación criminológica
y una evaluación de su situación social
y económica
a través de eso se integra un programa
donde se tocan temas muy específicos y
donde el más importante y que es el
punto de inflexión para que las jóvenes
cambien y para que las personas
cambiemos es el perdón
y la reconciliación
el perdón
hacia nosotros mismos
el perdón hacia la sociedad
la reconciliación de nosotros con
nosotros mismos y con la sociedad la
recuperación de nuestra dignidad
porque es algo un derecho inalienable
que nosotros pensamos que nadie nos
puede quitar pero que alguien que haya
vivido la experiencia estará adentro
sabe que es un derecho del cual es
privado desde el momento que entra
se trabaja con ellos a través de la ley
nacional de protección integral para
niños y adolescentes
esta ley está fundamentada en cuatro
puntos o cuatro bases que son los
derechos inalienables de los seres
humanos el derecho a la supervivencia y
el derecho al desarrollo
el derecho
al derecho del desarrollo del derecho
también al perdón se me se me fue un
poquito el tema de la participación y el
derecho también a la salud estos
derechos que conforman este programa a
nivel nacional esta ley son fundamentos
de los que nosotros estamos trabajando a
través de los cuales se han ejercido y
se han desarrollado estos cambios
datos importantes de este programa es
que el día de hoy de esos 508 jóvenes en
cinco ciudades del estado
en vez de tener un 70 por ciento de
reinserción tenemos menos del 1 por
ciento de reincidencia delictiva menos
del 1 contra 70 nacional ese es un dato
importante es una figura que está
empezando a establecerse no solo en la
ciudad y en el estado de chihuahua sino
que está trascendiendo otros estados y
está trascendiendo a otros países
latinoamericanos que están cubriendo
este programa que nació aquí
los jóvenes cambian
se integran a la sociedad perdona
e interactúan día a día con empresarios
con gente que les da una segunda
oportunidad en un trabajo con gente que
les abre las puertas para ver en ellos
una persona digna para ver en ellos una
persona que tiene la capacidad
de verde atrás y sin estigmatizar a la
persona que está ahí estos jóvenes están
listos
nosotros enfrentamos un reto como
sociedad y ese reto es no
estigmatizarlos ese reto es darle
oportunidades este reto es perdonarlos y
entender que ellos ya ha pagado
y la pregunta más importante para todos
nosotros en esta tarde es ellos están
listos nosotros como sociedad estamos
listos que tengamos una tarde